ونحن عددنا العده يعني واحضرنا كم كبير من
اج التنفس الصناعي اليدويه يعني عدنا الى
العصور ما قبل الوسطى حتى يعني نبقي يعني
مرضان على قيد
[موسيقى]
الحياه
احنا بالمناسبه في مستشفى الشفاء
وزعنا يعني هذه الكميات التي بحوزتنا من
الانبو باج او التنفس اليدوي الذي نستطيع
عندما ينقطع الكهرب غدا ان نقف مع مرضانا
لكي نعذر الى الله عز
وجل
[موسيقى]
ا
لكن هل نستطيع ان نستمر بعمل تنفس اصطناعي
يدوي كم ساعه كم دقيقه كم يوم لا تطيع
الطواقم الطبيه عمل ذلك
[موسيقى]
الان هم في خطر حقيقي هؤلاء الاطفال ربما
اذا انقطعت عنهم الكهرباء ستكون البيئه
الحضانه غير ملائمه درجه حراره غير ملائمه
ومنهم انهم على اي تنفس اصطناعي هذول
سيموت فورا اذا انقطعت عنهم
الكهرباء